Hey how's everyone doing today I'm gonna
start a new set of tutorials this is
going to be aimed at people who don't
really know JavaScript at all it's going
to be in essence a JavaScript for
beginners even JavaScript for absolute
beginners because I'm going to talk
about learning JavaScript from the
ground up this will assume really no
experience with JavaScript on your part
or even any experience with programming
on your part so if you're excited about
that idea then keep following to do a
brief overview of what to expect from
this first video and from the following
ones when I'm going to talk about today
is first off Who am I what's my
background then I'll talk about what
JavaScript is and why it might be useful
to you and why you might want to learn
it although if you're here you probably
have already decided that you do then
we'll go over some basic set up and he
did to get JavaScript running what we'll
do is we'll get something just
displaying on the screen saying hello
world and finally we'll go over some
tools associated with JavaScript
development so debuggers mostly it'll be
or mostly it'll be a quick tour of the
developer console in chrome which is
probably the meat and potatoes of
JavaScript development at least in the
browser to begin Who am I well this is
Simon dev so you can guess my name hello
my name is Simon I have about 18 years
experience in programming in general
split pretty evenly between game
development and at Google so on game
development I worked in C++ almost
exclusively and I was primarily an
optimization guy so you have the game
you need to run at 30 or 60 FPS frames
per second most developers are concerned
with just getting their features in and
you have someone like me who is
profiling the code having to understand
large swathes of it and figuring out how
to make things happen much faster at
Google I had a variety of roles I've
worked on internal projects on external
projects like Chrome I've led teams and
I mostly worked
in C++ there although by the end I was
starting to do some Python and even a
tiny tiny bit of JavaScript I wasn't
actually writing the JavaScript myself
that was mostly at that point reviewing
other people's JavaScript so I managed
to learn a little bit but not a whole
lot this set of tutorials will follow me
actually learning along with you and
what I'll be doing is so what I'll be
doing is walking you through how I would
learn a new language because I will be
learning a new language to begin what is
JavaScript you can see from the
Wikipedia page JavaScript often
abbreviated as J s is a high-level
just-in-time compiled object-oriented
programming language that conforms to
the ECMO script specification yeah that
I would recommend quickly reading the
JavaScript Wikipedia page but we'll go
over some of the details here if you're
unfamiliar with high-level it just means
that it abstracts away a lot of the
details of the underlying computer you
don't need to know what you're running
on you could be running on a smartphone
you could be running on a computer you
could be running on some magical system
and Xbox who know the point is that you
write your JavaScript and you don't need
to know the details of the computer
just-in-time compiled just-in-time
compilation just refers to the way that
the the code is executed so when you
when you visit a webpage and the
JavaScript is downloaded it's not
downloaded in compiled form chrome
chrome actually compiles that as it's
executing Chrome as a library in it
called v8 v8 is the JavaScript engine v8
takes the uncompelled code in a web page
and compiles it to run on your computer
now why do you want to learn JavaScript
often javascript is associated with
being a front-end language and this is
pretty true so when you're surfing the
web and you're visiting web pages that
is all JavaScript running you've got
HTML and JavaScript and CSS and whatever
else but that's why it's often
associated with being a front-end
language
but there's a lot of other use for it
you can do a lot of game development in
JavaScript directly in your browser so
let's just quickly look at one of the
some of the common libraries here you
can do 2d development so here is a very
popular library called phaser that I've
used a little bit you can see that it
supports a whole bunch of doing things
physics animation particles that kind of
thing and it even runs on the phone so
if you write JavaScript for the browser
you can actually get it onto your phone
we'll cover that at some point later
it's not just 2d there's three D
available as well so you can do 3d game
development and it's fully hardware
accelerated GPU accelerated shaders
shader support the works dude to do
let's just go check out some of these
demos here
you can see here you can do some pretty
cool stuff in JavaScript in your browser
and there's tons of other libraries so
let's for example tensorflow Google's
machine learning oriented library
there's it's available in multiple
languages including JavaScript so you
can run machine learning models in your
browser there's a common misnomer that
JavaScript is just a front-end language
while other languages like Python go our
back-end or server-side languages and
this is totally wrong there are projects
that get JavaScript running on the
backend as well
so let's look so let's look up nodejs
nodejs is a JavaScript runtime and what
that means is that it provides a way to
execute JavaScript code outside for the
browser on the backend server and so you
can be a full-stack developer who knows
just JavaScript a lot of the major cloud
offerings also offer javascript
libraries so again you can run this both
on the front end and on the back end and
so that means that you can deploy a
fleet of servers manage them all run
them all terminate instances all excited
etc all from nodejs all on the back end
and then of course you can build out
your front-end on something like react
with that out of the way let's get an
environment set up so that you can run a
piece of JavaScript so to do JavaScript
development I would recommend three
basic things to start number one you
need an editor number two you need some
way to host the JavaScript files so that
so that we can navigate to them in the
browser and three you need a browser
with development tools of some kind
I recommend chrome and I'll be doing
these tutorials in chrome
I kind of like to use Python to serve my
files it's a bit weird using a different
language but it's really really simple
and maybe if we find something better
maybe nodejs has something later we'll
go and switch to that in a later
tutorial but for now I'm just gonna go
with Python if you don't have Python
installed like if you're running these
tutorials from Windows then I would
recommend going to get it it's as simple
as just typing Python in the search and
hitting the download button
now there's Python three point eight and
there's Python 2.7 in our case for
hosting code there's a little bit of a
difference but not a huge one so I would
just go with the latest Python three
point eight we also need an editor you
can use any editor you want you can use
notepad you can use VI you can use nano
Emacs any of those ones that come free
with your computer depending on your oh
s it doesn't matter
I prefer atom I like to have a little
bit of a fancy UI so I like to have
syntax highlighting I like to get the
niceties of integration with I like to
get the niceties of things like
auto-completion find and replace all of
that all of that cool stuff you can also
edit the theme you can make it look
however you want and Adam kind of checks
all those boxes for me and as you can
see it runs on OSX windows and linux so
anybody who's following this tutorial
can go and get Adam and run it now
whatever you happen to choose it doesn't
really matter that much we're not going
to focus we're not going to focus deeply
on which editor you choose and you can
probably if you see me do something in
my editor that you don't have you can
probably figure out what I did
what's going to be holding you back is
not your choice of editor so just pick
one and get started
as I said Adam I really like Adam it
works very well and the nice thing is is
it's free it's completely free there are
some other ones you can go look at
sublime for example you can go look at
sublime text for example it's really
versatile and has a lot of nice commands
as well so you can you can go to files
you can autocomplete you can do a lot of
that cool stuff that a modern that a
modern editor allows you to do and
sublime also runs on Mac Linux and
Windows so you know it's up to you and
sublime also runs on Mac Linux or
Windows so it's not a big deal if you
want to grab this instead the only thing
I don't like about sublime is that it it
does occasionally ask you to pay for it
I'm not opposed to paying for software
but if there are but if there is
software that exists that is nearly
identical and free then I'll just take
the free version so let's get started
let's get some code running in the
browser what I'm going to show you first
is the dev tools or the chrome developer
tools and these are incredibly important
to get to know as a JavaScript developer
so we're just going to find them here in
the little uh I'm not sure what to call
those little three dots things but you
click there go to more tools and then
developer tools now you can see that
there is a keyboard shortcut that will
bring you directly there you can press
control shift hi or at least on mine on
my machine you can press control shift I
it might be different on yours but we'll
just navigate to it directly for now I'm
going to open that
and you can see that here we have the
developer tool now there's a whole bunch
of tabs here and I will dedicate an
entire tutorial on what these mean and
which ones are important for you
at least early on for now we're just
going to go to the console here so what
this is is it allows you to type in
valid JavaScript and it will execute on
the page so all you do is you type in
here so we're just going to type
something that outputs hello and hit
enter the console dot log function is a
way for us to log debugging information
to to this page to this tab right here
which is the console so other one wasn't
very exciting when you type console dot
log it shows up here if the code was
executing on the page and you want to
write out some debugging information you
want to write out something to help you
figure out what went wrong that kind of
thing then you can use console dot log
statements throughout your code and
it'll show up here in this in this
console tab and so when I wrote console
dot log it said hello and then this just
means that it didn't return anything
now this demo just get some JavaScript
running but it's not on the page it's
not in any kind of useful spot so what
we're gonna do now is we're gonna load a
page that has JavaScript on it so that
you can see JavaScript running in the
browser and not just in the console what
we're gonna do is go make a file called
index.html and we're gonna write some
we're gonna write some HTML in there to
begin
what I did here was I just made an HTML
page and I filled it with some
boilerplate code all this does is makes
a really basic HTML page so we specify
the HTML tag this is the head element so
we have the title that will appear in
the we have the title that will appear
in the browser and then the body is what
is going to appear in the actual on the
page itself and so what we should see is
something that just says first
JavaScript project and hello on the page
what I'm gonna do is just press control
Oh
and navigate directly to the file and
open it and you can see hello hello and
you can see that the name in the tab is
first JavaScript project now there's no
actual JavaScript running here all we've
done is create an element that says
hello so let's make some JavaScript run
here I'm just going to go back to the
index.html and add a script element
what I've done here is I've added a
script element and between the opening
and closing tags they see the tag here
where the slash is the closing one I've
just written some pure JavaScript in
here and now we reload and bang and
there we go hello from the console so
we've actually executed javascript in
the browser that you were it that you
wrote in the index.html file now you're
not limited to just outputting some text
in the console you can when you're
running JavaScript on the page you can
manipulate what's called the Dom or the
document object model which is the
representation of the page let's go and
make the hello say something else and
we'll do that from the console to begin
with
what I'm doing here is I'm adding an ID
to the to the hello text and that'll
allow us to find it really easily on the
page through JavaScript I've opened up
the console again and what I'm gonna do
is I'm going to just grab that element
on the page and manipulate it what I
what I did there was I used the document
get element by ID function to get the
element that I named ID and I changed
the text from hello to good but this
should give you a glimpse as as to what
JavaScript running on the page can do
you can programmatically rewrite the
entire page from JavaScript you can
create and destroy elements change
elements do a whole bunch of stuff the
last thing I want to do is I want to
structure this code a little bit better
because running the code directly in the
HTML file although it works for our
example we should at least get ourselves
set up to start down the path of bigger
projects and better modularization so
the next step is to move this javascript
into a file on its own and load it from
the HTML file and that's the last thing
we're gonna do today so we're gonna go
back to the index.html file
and I'm going to create a new file you
can see that I named at Maine Jas and I
changed the script element here to
reference the Maine dot J's file that I
just created so now let's go back to the
browser and this is not going to work
you can see here that this is this
didn't work and the reason it didn't
work is because we're just loading the
file directly and so anytime you
reference files externally you're going
to get something like this and that's
because we don't have a full proper
environment set up to do anything even
remotely beyond even remotely beyond a
little hello world type of program so
you remember that I mentioned getting
Python what we're gonna do is you're
gonna open the terminal window on
windows this would be a command line
prompt and you're going to go to your
JavaScript directory the one that you've
got the index.html and main J's files in
now I recommend you put them in their
own directory you don't want to host a
million other things and we're going to
use Python to launch a really simple
HTTP server in fact there's actually
called simple HTTP server
what it does is it launches the simple
HTTP server module that comes with
Python that's just a lightweight server
that serves files for you so when I
press ENTER you're gonna see now serving
HTTP on 0 0 0 0 port 8000 and that means
that you can now go in your browser and
you can navigate to localhost 8080 is
just the port that we're running on and
you can see that the file is loaded and
let's bring up the dev console and you
can see that it ran the JavaScript you
can ignore this will fail to reload
resource we didn't bother putting in a
favicon so it doesn't matter but you can
see that the JavaScript that you put in
that file ran and if we go and change it
now let's add something else
and we can go and reload and there you
go you'll notice that I ran this using
Python - I have a simple HTTP server
that's because my default Python is
Python 2.7 if you're running Python 3.8
or whatever you're going to need to
change the command a little bit so I'll
write the command here and you'll see
that it works just fine so I'll write
the command here now I have to write
Python 3 so that I specify that I'm
using Python 3 you'll just write Python
and as you can see there goes same thing
and that's it so you've got some
JavaScript running you've got some of
the basic so you've got some JavaScript
running in your browser you've got an
idea of where a lot of your debugging
tools are that's the developer tools in
chrome you've got a way to host the
JavaScript and you've got an editor of
some kind so next time I'll go over some
of the other tabs you've got elements
console sources Network performance
memory application security and audits
these are all very complex and you can
talk for hours about each one I'm going
to just do a quick tour of each one and
probably focus on the first three
because those are the ones especially
when you're first learning are the most
relevant and interesting to you so stay
tuned for that if you were able to get
this working please let me know in the
comments and I'll see you next time
Cheers